We know Tony is gonna fight bad guys and robots and that kind of thing,...
...but what's his internal struggle this time around?
We are not as serious as the Dark Knight...
...but Tony definitely has, and always has historically in the comic books,...
...even more so, his inner demons.
We did a little of that in Iron Man 2,...
...but if you think about someone who saw the skies open up...
...and came through a wormhole and fought off alien species,...
...suffice to say he's a little rattled.
Robert, we heard that you're signed up to do a big stunt...
...where you're going to be running across some major high point.
Are you giving Tom Cruise a run for his money here?
Oh, well I don't know.
I just said while I'm still physically able, I'd like to leave it all on the field.
And I would like there to be ten moments where people wonder...
...how I was stupid enough to actually do that stunt, most of all me.
What is Rhodes's relationship with Tony in this film?
Are they on good terms now?
They kind of kissed and made up at the end of Iron Man 2...
...and this one starts off with him.
There's still some, there's always this underlying sort of competitiveness and suit envy...
...between both of them which is kind of fun.
As Shane is fond of saying, they're kind of two Iron Men,...
...one of them who's private sector Iron Man and the other one is this military Iron Man...
...and what's their jurisdiction and where's the overlap happening...
...how does it make each of them feel.
So a lot more of that gets looked into in this film.